yeah boy looks like it worth it
[Music]
[ __ ]
so chips is a movie based on the old
series chips I don't really know much
about it other than it was a cop show I
had Erik Estrada in it that's what I
know this was written and directed by
Dax Shepard ultimately Michael Pena he's
an FBI agent who goes to Luis California
Highway Patrol because CHP ship he gets
teamed up with Dax Shepard who's his ex
BMX biker who's a rookie straight arrow
straight edge dude almost to a naive
degree which is a complete conflict of
his character we'll get into that later
point is they're teamed up they hate
each other they have to solve a case
they have no chemistry here's Chester
yeah well work in this movie alright
let's talk about Michael Pena because
Michael Pena is great as a great actor
he's a great comedic actor little about
Michael Pena is even in movies that are
not comedies he can bring in endearing
comedic quality that just makes it
realistic like is that funny person you
know in real life and he's great at it
you really is I love that he tried he
really did try his best in this one that
is pretty much what I like basically
guys here comes the point right here
this movie working all hinges on the
chemistry of Michael Pena and Dax
Shepard and it is not here it doesn't
work they just don't work well together
now if they're friends in real life and
they have that chemistry real live
awesome but it just doesn't come through
on screen at all for most of this movie
they hate each other which is fine if a
couple of new partners in a film have
growing pains but it's kind of toxic it
is not fun to watch as movies a comedy
is supposed to be fun
you're not having fun watching these two
hate each other it feels like they're
just splitting up with each other which
makes you feel like you're putting up
with them which makes you feel like
you're putting up with the movies which
you are part and partial to the fact
that their characters are mixed up it's
not best-case-scenario their characters
are causes of each other's characters
like the a there's this character of
that character you know what slice them
in half and we'll mix some of their
attributes and qualities and now it's
like this is a Frankenstein one version
of that person that's a Frankenstein
other version of that person like Jack
Shepard is the ex BMX biker he's busted
a bunch of bones in his body you would
think he would be the hothead trolling
for ass in the movie and you would think
Michael Pena would be the nice guy
trying to save his marriage almost to a
naive degree but it's not like that it's
reversed Dax Shepard xbm
ex biker is the nice rookie trying to
save his marriage to a naive degree
where he comes to me like hey honey hey
who's that guy in the pool da is fine
the Michael Pena is like oh man I love
yoga pants that as I need to [ __ ] so
many chicks you're like the lack of
chemistry of the characters aside also
very important thing in a comedy is to
laughs I didn't there are a couple of
chuckle moments there in here a couple
of them but ultimately a lot of the
jokes didn't organically weave into the
plot and script itself one scene in
particular high-speed chase a couple
people civilians get nailed they're
probably dead one of the cops looks back
is like it's paparazzi it's fine I get
it paparazzi joke but in the digits
wasn't funny and are we going to address
the fact that are there any
repercussions to those cops ran over
civilians there's one joke in this movie
that hinges on you knowing through this
one character is that you've seen once
briefly in its scene near the beginning
the longer times like who was everything
I don't know who that person is then the
movie tells you who that person is like
oh oh that one scene that was really
brief as far other than the chemistry
not working and a lot of it here we're
not working the physics of the movie
just don't work either look I know it's
a comedy it doesn't have to be perfect
physics wise but there are realities you
just can't escape so when a big
explosion happens that wipes out this
one-story building when everyone in it
is perfectly fine I find that strange
like imagine terminator few were miles
Bennett dices like huddle how much
longer like it closes and it blows the
entire floor I just walked out of it
he's like whoa little toast in there
even when that happened with Tom Hanks
in the burbs at least the movie
addressed the fact that he was burned
this [ __ ] and all his friends thought he
was dead just wanted to just kind of
blink and then they go about the next
thing every time and I was younger like
20 years ago I wrote a script that if I
read it now I'm like but it was 20 years
ago there's a sniper taking out people
this one dude does the Batman he puts
the cookie sheet under his shirt and a
sniper boom shoots him the sniper think
he's dead and boom reveal cookie sheet
with a dent in it problem is there's a
sniper rifle that bullet would cook
through the cookie sheet his chest his
back and a few layers of wall and I know
that and I know it's not good I was a
kid when I wrote it I was Jack Shepard
to have that excuse when he wrote this
and if he does if he did write chips
when he was a kid he probably should
have rewritten that set guys in the end
I'm wrapping this one up Michael
and Dax Shepard have no on-screen
chemistry the jokes didn't work a lot of
them fell flat movie made no sense I was
literally praying for it to end so I
could just kill Oh Matt in the end guys
chip is exactly what you think it is
chips is [ __ ] alright guys so chips
don't see it's my question is what's one
of the worst comedies you've ever seen
in your life whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]